oui oui normalement à cette période de
l'année la semence hier l'une bellemare
travail avec un seul employé il cette
année les activités ont repris beaucoup
plus rapidement l'habitude de janvier
c'est calme ça commence en février puis
le groupe x et en mars
mélo en janvier onu l'achalandage de
mars est beaucoup plus dès le début
janvier jean noël sa commande et dans
les trois premières semaines de janvier
on a fait le tiers de notre chiffre
d'affaires annuel l'entreprise
spécialisée dans les semences ancestrale
cultive un hectare à des bizarres elle
amène ensuite les semences dans ce local
de montréal pour les faire sécher les
nettoyer puis les mettre en sachet et
les envoyer aux clients ce qui part très
rapidement cessé les concombres les
laitues les haricots
on n'a presque plus de réserves de là
dessus les haricots non plus on ne les
melons melon montréal melon d'eau cos
allaient quand même ça passe très très
bien c'est nos meilleurs vendeurs donc
les melons je pense pas je vais être
capable de terminer l'année avec notre
stock de melons les réserves seront à
sec d'ici deux à trois semaines pour les
haricots et les points
heureusement les semences de tomate elle
devrait suffire à la forte demande
on s'attendait à une hausse quand même
parce que les gens sont à la maison ils
veulent jardiner peuvent pas voyager
donc qu ils peuvent avoir un jardin
mais jamais jamais jamais j'aurais pensé
ça j'aurais jamais pensé que ça l'aurait
été si gros que ça si la vague est plus
fort qu'attendu et les biens accueillis
par l'équipe de terre promise
c'est bien que les gens prennent le
temps je pense qu'avec le temps avant
mais de s'intéresser à comment la
nourriture produite qui en produisent
eux-mêmes vont peut-être comprendre tous
les enjeux qui a derrière la production
que tout ce que ça implique des
maraîchers par exemple produire tout
elle nous étonne
cet intérêt est partagé par plusieurs
gens qu'on raison du contexte qui
échangea donc moi je trouve que c'est
une super bonne nouvelle même si ça nous
donne beaucoup de travail
si vous comptez cultiver un jardin cet
été mieux vous commandez vos semences
assez rapidement mais rien ne sert d'en
commander trop calculer vos besoins
selon la surface disponible
c'est marie claude morin radio canada
montréal